the court in Malaysia has dropped all
corruption charges against the Deputy
Prime Minister Ahmed zahid hamidi who
was on trial for 47 counts at bribery
money laundering and the criminal breach
of trust Florence Louis has more
the public prosecutor had applied for a
discharge not amounting to an acquittal
and one of the reasons cited was to
enable a more comprehensive
investigation to be carried out against
zahid hamidi the Deputy Prime Minister
of Malaysia now this case has generated
quite a lot of interest because zahid is
one of several high-ranking officials to
be charged with corruption in 2018.
that's the year the um no party which
had never lost an election previously
was voted out of power because of
widespread anger over corruption zahid's
former boss the former prime minister of
Malaysia najib razak is currently
serving a prison sentence after being
found guilty of graft but amno of which
zahid is party president is back in
power last year it joined forces with a
coalition led by prime minister Anwar
Ibrahim part of the very Alliance that
had defeated amno in 2018.
anwar's Coalition did not win enough
seats after last year's general election
and it needed and still needs amno to
form government now last September zahid
was acquitted in a separate bribery case
after the judge rule there had been
insufficient evidence against him in
this case however because what he's been
granted is a discharge not amounting to
an acquittal that still means the
prosecution can still bring those same
charges against him in the future
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur